everything is possible you know when you
believe
that's
the kind of kicker you have to believe
but it's not that hard it's really
pretty easy
our belief
creates our entire life experience
and so you can't if i put it this way
you can't experience anything in life
that is outside of your own beliefs
so and that's that's the case for every
single one of us we really can't
experience anything
that's outside of our beliefs if we
can't experience anything that's outside
of our beliefs
what that means is look at all those
hearts that's so beautiful
what that means is there's not really
one world we kind of think there's one
world but there isn't really
because we're all experiencing a world
based on our beliefs and not one of us
has the same beliefs not one of us so
that means there's a different world for
every one of us
so
all of your beliefs
are held in your subconscious mind and
the subconscious mind is just a part of
your mind there's the conscious mind and
then there's the subconscious mind which
is actual which is actually higher than
the conscious mind and so we use our
conscious mind with all of the thoughts
and everything that we have our
conscious mind is very present right
and so
to create anything
you are using your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is what
is really what creates if i want to make
it really really simple then i would say
your subconscious mind is what creates
it makes things appear
and manifest things
and that's where all of your beliefs are
stored kind of neat huh
because you have to believe to manifest
something
and your subconscious mind creates
everything so you can see it's all kind
of perfectly designed
um so now to manifest you have to
believe
and you have to believe that you already
have whatever it is that you want
and the reason that you have to believe
you have it already is because the
subconscious mind
is only operating in the present
it can't reason
it's just like a program
so if you say
for example
um
a new car is coming my new car is coming
i'm going to get a new car it's coming
well then it's always going to be coming
right that's the that's the thing you
have to imagine you have it now
you have to go off and you have to test
drive the car you've got to feel the car
smell the car and just then visualize
being in that car
and then when you do that that's how
if you do that enough that's how you'll
come to believe that you actually have
the car and the moment that you believe
there's manifestations instantaneous
so
so
the other ways to believe is to affirm
over and over and over um
so
to be really repetitive for example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful
because when we close our eyes and we
put ourselves in the picture and you
must make sure you're in the picture
and you put yourself in the picture with
whatever it is that you want and you
close your eyes and you just kind of
create this mini movie
honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea
it just sees that movie and recreates it
it's like a giant photocopying machine
it will just whatever you hold in your
mind it will
photocopy it warm into the world so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if
and for example
if you wanted to attract the perfect
partner
are you acting as if your perfect
partner's here already and so there are
just small things that you can do that
are super super powerful for example are
you sleeping in the middle of your bed
or are you sleeping on one side of the
bed because your partner's on the other
side of the bed do you have room in your
wardrobe for your perfect partner's
clothes
is there room in your bathroom for their
toothbrush and for their things and so
you see they are just little things you
can set the table for two you don't have
to put food on the plate but just
setting the table for two is really
really powerful it's saying my perfect
partner is here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it
and your perfect partner will be
attracted to you through the most
incredible circumstances so
um if something hasn't manifested yet
and you really really want it
and i i doubt there's anybody out there
who's
who wants something and it has a
manifesto right i mean
um i'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how you can
magnetize yourself towards money
joy
rule number two stop four saint outcomes
with gabby bernstein true manifesting is
about receiving what is of the highest
good for all this is probably one of the
most
profound
ways to look at life
when we stop expecting things to be the
way that we think they should be
when we stop forcing outcomes and when
we start allowing what is of the highest
good to be our only agenda our only
intention
that's when the universe truly has our
back that's when we can
live what it means to surrender true
surrender comes when we stop
praying for what we think we need and we
start
connecting and grounding in what could
possibly be of the highest
good for all
and when we stop praying for what we
think we need and we start allowing what
is of the highest good for all
so true manifesting is about receiving
what is of the highest good for all and
it begins not just with what well how
will i get what is of the highest good
but how can i be open to what is of the
highest good how can i open up my
consciousness to release what i think i
need and get grounded in what is
possible
and what is of the highest good not just
for me and my agenda but the highest
good for all that's the message so
you're doing everything right in that
you're
open to a spiritual practice you're
willing to grow you're showing up for
your practice you're reading books
you're doing the work you're here on
dear gabby you're showing up you're
showing up you're showing up you're
doing a lot of doing though and you're
also doing a lot of expecting and so a
lot of doing and a lot of expecting are
two major blocks to your ability to
attract what it is that you want into
your life and so it's the doing doing
doing that actually creates sort of a
manic manifesting vibration which is how
do i get that how do what am i what do i
do next got to do this thing next got to
do this thing next and that lacks the
belief system that i can be still and i
can allow
that's number one
number two being in the expectation of
what you think things should be is
another block to your manifesting power
and your super attractor power which is
what i call it because your expectations
are limiting the possibilities your
expectations are limiting the highest
good as this card says so when we start
to pray for what is of the highest good
rather than intend and pray for what we
think we need that's when the universe
can conspire with what it is that is of
the highest good for all
so ultimately what's happening is all
the doing doing doing is energetically
blocking
and all the expecting expecting
expecting is blocking the manifestation
as well because when you're in this
tunnel vision of expectation it should
be this way i should be further along i
shouldn't be here what's happening is
you're missing the opportunity to
recognize where you are how great things
are in this moment what is possible in
this moment the creative possibility in
this moment the exciting potential in
this moment you're blocking it blocking
it blocking it blocking and blocking it
blocking it
i want you to sit on your ass
i want you to stop doing doing doing
i want you to
start being being
being which is what you also said you're
actually dear gabbying yourself
you said i want to embody the feeling i
want to embody the emotion
the being
is a presence it's an energy it's a
state
it's not an action
true manifesting does require
us to show up for our desires you've got
to pick up the phone and then call the
job interview and you have to ask for
the date and you have to to do whatever
it is that you want to create but
ultimately
the greatest source of power that we
have to attract what we want is how we
feel rule number three train your brain
with john assaraf so many people ask me
is it possible to train your brain
to help you make more money
and the answer
is yes so maybe i can share a story with
you of how i started to train my own
brain to help me make more money
and it started with setting some goals
for the kind of lifestyle that i wanted
to live and my mentor
walter schneider many years ago i was a
very very successful businessman
and he said in order to achieve your
goals he said first you have to have the
clarity of what they are
so let's say you have a financial goal
of making let's say a hundred thousand
dollars a year okay that's about eighty
five hundred dollars a month or about
you know twenty one hundred fifty
dollars every week that you wanna earn
and let's say you're not earning that
right now
one of the things you can do to train
your brain
to help you make that amount of money
is first and foremost get clear on the
exact amount you want to earn whether
it's per week per month or per year
that's step number one
step number two
create a simple affirmation that goes
like this
i am so happy and grateful for the fact
that i am now earning
10 000 a month
simple affirmation
and what i want you to do is i want you
to read that affirmation
every single morning
five to ten times and every single night
before you go to bed five to ten times
and as you read that affirmation i want
you to close your eyes
and i want you to practice mentally
rehearse
you
receiving that money in the form of a
check or cash or in your bank account
and see the money going into your bank
account i want you to feel what it feels
like to consistently have ten thousand
dollars a month coming into your bank up
and you can choose whatever amount you
want by the way
and as you close your eyes and you
visualize that money coming into your
account what i also want you to
visualize is the impact that that amount
of money will have on your life your
family's life your friend's life the
community that you live in and the
charities that you want to support get
totally into a mental movie
and the emotions
as if you were a hollywood actor or
actors pretending that that was really
happening
so you'd read
your affirmation i'm so happy and
grateful for the fact that i am now
earning ten thousand dollars a month
and as you do that and you repeat that
mentally rehearse visualize
what that looks like
and what that does is that primes your
brain
to see and feel as if it is real right
now and that activates the different
parts of your brain specifically
the left prefrontal cortex which is the
genius ceo einstein part of your brain
that can actually help you figure out
how to achieve that goal and dream
so if you do that in the morning and at
night before bed morning upon waking up
night time before bed you will start to
prime your brain with an affirmation
with a mental rehearsal and you will
cognitively prime your brain and if you
want a bonus step what i want you to do
is take a vision board either on your
computer
or a physical board and cut out some
pictures of what lifestyle
earning 10 000 a month will allow you to
live what kind of car would you drive
what kind of places would you go
vacation and what kind of home would you
live in what kind of charities would you
support get pictures of the outcome of
earning ten thousand dollars a month is
or a hundred thousand dollars a year and
start to see yourself
in that scenario and act as if it is
real right now
and then
every day ask yourself a question what
can i do today
to make that amount of income a reality
and take one or two action steps towards
making that a reality so the physical
actions
in addition to the mental rehearsal with
affirmations and mental rehearsals
visualizations
is one of the best ways to start priming
your brain
to achieve the financial goals you have
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four have a vision
with jack canfield it can't be
successful without a vision and being
clear well you have to first take 100
responsibility for your life give up
being a victim then you have to get
clear about what is my purpose i believe
each person has a purpose they were born
with whether it's to be a mechanic or a
chef or to be a doctor or to be do what
we do which is empower and enlighten
people uh through the work we do and so
once you've got that you have to have a
clear vision of what would you like your
life to look like both in the business
world in your social world and your
relationships your health and fitness
your travel and fun all of that so we
have seven areas of your life which we
say let's let's pretend that you can
have anything you want no holds barred
you know god comes down and says you're
chosen you won the lottery you get the
life you want what would you do and you
go oh i'd like to live in this house and
malibu i'd like to live on the ocean i
want to have three kids i want to be
able to travel to europe five times you
know whatever it is write it down and
then using things like visualization and
affirmations you can start turbo
charging that vision with intention and
then some of the tools that come out of
the law of attraction work and so forth
but you first have to know where you're
going i liken it to a gps system in a
car here we are in santa barbara you
live in l.a somewhere why need roads to
get back here yeah and but if you have a
gps that says 929 via fury or whatever
your gps system will tell you how to get
there now when you left la you did not
know exactly where you were going you
just trusted a gps to say turn left turn
right
your subconscious mind works the exact
same way it is a programmable gps system
that will figure out the path if you
program it correctly which is putting in
a vision of the destination that's all
you have to do interesting but a lot of
people uh feel a lot of fear because
they're of the unknown of what's going
to happen or that they might fail if
they have a big dream right
so what is fear to you and how does
someone overcome that fear well here's
here's the deal you know basically fear
is i love this word the guy who wrote
the book dune said fear is the mind
killer fear takes you back into the
amygdala which is in the limbic system
of your brain you want to be in the
prefrontal cortex which is where the
executive functions where spiritual
insights where wisdom occurs where
rational logical thinking occurs so
basically as soon as i get into fear i
go back into this primal fight or flight
or freeze place and so i want to be up
here
so
you know basically we now have
technology called eft tapping i'm sure
you can
nick ortner and all those guys and
literally nine acupuncture points you
tap on those in a sequence for maybe
five minutes seven minutes and the fear
disappears it literally dissolves
there's absolutely no reason for anyone
to be in fear now the value of setting a
goal is to watch all these fears come up
i refer to it as a if you ever played
the game whack-a-mole at the moment yeah
yeah yeah you got your head you got to
whack them before they go back down so
we want to surface those fears so we can
whack them using eft and other
technologies that are out there
neuro-linguistic programming and so
forth but now it we have this science
that just literally you don't have to be
stopped the other thing a friend of mine
just wrote a book called the the the
fear cure and or the cure for fear one
of those and
she talked about one of the biggest
fears is of the unknown and uncertainty
of the future
but
everything's uncertain you know we're
trying to create certainty in an
uncertain world and stop being afraid of
uncertainty uncertainty is what's
exciting if you go to africa on a
vacation a safari you have no idea
what's going to happen that's part of
the adventure fun that's part of the fun
exactly if you knew oh there's gonna be
a zebra that pops out right here this is
gonna be nice it might get boring right
or if you go river rafting you don't
know where the rapids are and how you're
gonna do it and if you go surfing you
don't know exactly how the wave is going
to break and all that and how big it's
going to be and so that adventure is
really what life's about so we need to
be excited fear
is created by imagining bad things that
haven't happened yet so fantasized
experiences appearing real everyone
always says that someone else recently
said forget everything and run but
but i think that if you realize that
you're creating your own fear by
imagining a bad thing oh if there's a
recession i'll lose my house why not go
if there was a recession i'm going to
make more money because there's going to
be opportunities and we're going to be
able to pay our house out faster
zig ziglar said worrying is negative
goal setting
and all you have to do is use that same
power to think and visualize to create a
positive outcome instead of a negative
and then the fear disappears yeah and a
quarter of yours i believe is in the
book
uh as you say everything you want is on
the other side of fear absolutely you
know we all live in our comfort zone we
want to be comfortable when i was down
in the rain forest a couple years ago
with the achoir indians i always wanted
to go to the rainforest ever since i
heard how was it it was so cool that's
really cool we got to live with the
ochoar indians which is an indigenous
tribe which is uh you know had not had
any connection with white people from
the outer world until about 10 years ago
15 years ago
and friends of mine are down now working
with them to help preserve the rain
forest and i always wanted to go and the
trees are unbelievably huge roots are as
tall as this building and go out like
that you can build a house inside the
root system oh my goodness there's army
ants that are about that big these leaf
cutter ants and you can see them just
like going across with all these little
leafs waving we got to swim in this
river that was full of piranha they told
us later but piranha don't eat you
they they don't they they have a rule in
the river nothing attacks anything six
times bigger than it is wow and so if
you are in a tide pool where you there's
no food
and you know there's flooded now it's
stuck over there and you step in there
prana will bite you but the river
they're not going to not not at all we
had so much fun it was so delightful to
be in that nature so
the point is everything is an adventure
and we have to think of it that way or
we're going to be victims number five
understand money with mary kate
in order to start attracting money into
your life you have to first have an
understanding of what money is and your
relationship to your finances that
sounds like such a strange statement to
say your relationship with your finances
but we all have feelings and
relationships to thoughts and objects
how you feel about something determines
how you can attract it into your life
everything is energy and in order to
attract certain things into your life
you have to be an energetic match and
understand your relationship to that
object love is one of the most powerful
vibrations you can tap into so whenever
possible shift your feelings towards
love
so what is your relationship to money be
honest with yourself
do you get nervous to check your bank
account do you feel anxious that you
don't have enough money do you
constantly tell yourself that you can't
afford things do you think that only
lucky people deserve money do you think
you have to work long hours at a job you
hate in order to earn enough money
i used to have that last belief and i
was stuck for way too long at a job i
hated working crazy long hours to
support the kind of life that i wanted
to deserve and once i shifted my mindset
i realized that none of that was worth
it once i shifted this mindset
everything started flowing to me so much
quicker and easier and i wasn't stuck at
a job that i hated anymore i want you to
write down a list of everything you feel
towards money all of your thoughts
feelings emotions doubts opinions write
it all down get very clear and be
completely honest with yourself pause
this video now and take as much time as
you need
after you write down your belief system
about money
look at specific areas at where you can
improve your money mindset for example
are you scared to check your bank
account how can you turn that around and
make it into a more positive action can
you start checking it more often and
release that fear that you don't need
can you use a positive affirmation each
time you look at that statement
can you meditate and visualize your bank
account with six figures do whatever is
in your power to shift your money
mindset so that everything lines up to
be clear and positive by understanding
your relationship with money and
releasing the fear or negative feelings
surrounding it you can be open to
attracting more of it into your life how
can you admit the frequency of love
surrounding money the vibrational
frequency of love is so unbelievably
strong that if you can tap into that
power money will flow to you at record
speed trust me there are so many ways to
add the frequency of love into your
money mindset for example you can
visualize how you would spend that money
on the people you love you can start
loving the money that you currently have
you can start generously making
donations to people in need and coming
from a place of love you can make vision
boards of all the things that you would
treat yourself to with that money give
yourself some self-love
you can meditate with the feeling of
love while visualizing complete
financial freedom
or one of my favorites you can visualize
your heart as a powerful magnet strongly
attracting money directly into your
reality
try out a few of these and see which one
works best for you now that you're clear
on your money mindset and infused it
with the vibration of love i want to
share with you the magic formula for
manifesting this formula is something i
go into more depth in my digital course
abundance academy but because this
formula really works i want to share it
with you thought has the magnetic force
thought coupled with feelings is even
stronger thought coupled with feelings
mixed with inspired action is where
manifesting occurs or put simply
thought plus feelings plus inspired
action equals manifesting welcome to
manifesting math class
like i said earlier everything starts
with thought and mindset you have to be
clear and understand what your thoughts
are towards money before you can start
to manifest it into your life once you
are clear on your thoughts it's time to
infuse it with feelings i suggest
infusing with love because it's the most
powerful frequency but if you want to
choose another feeling feel free do
whatever works best for you you can try
joy excitement happiness comfort peace
of mind or any feeling that you can emit
at a high frequency and this last step
is one that most people miss or skip in
their manifesting process
inspired action inspired action is one
of the most important and most
overlooked steps
taking an inspired action doesn't have
to be a huge deal it doesn't have to be
this overwhelming stressful thing so
don't worry inspired action can be as
simple as writing a check to yourself
for a hundred thousand dollars as a hint
to your subconscious that that's what
you're trying to create or
making a small donation to charity
because you are doing it from a place of
abundance or
following that urge you had to write
that blog or start that business or
follow up on that email your intuition
is always trying to communicate with you
and by taking guided inspired actions
you are directly aligning with whatever
it is that you're trying to manifest
get in touch with your intuition and see
what inspired action you're guided to
take there is always an option to take
an inspired action so take advantage of
it think of your intuition like your
fairy godmother you follow your
manifesting formula of thought plus
feeling and your intuition or your fairy
godmother will guide you to exactly
where you need to be in order to
manifest what you want but it's up to
you to follow that intuition and take
that step or inspired action with this
mindset work and manifesting formula you
are well on your way to start attracting
money into your life easily and
effortlessly but you have to remember
that you are in charge of redirecting
your negative thoughts or feelings about
money when they come up because they
will come up from time to time and just
remember that you are in charge of
shifting it right back to where you need
to be you need to get to the point of
ignoring your current or outside
circumstances and standing firm in a
place of faith that you are abundant
whenever you get a bill in the mail pay
it and be grateful that you're
contributing to someone else's financial
betterment whenever you feel stressed
about finances redirect yourself and
realize how lucky you are that you have
a roof over your head and clean water
and people that love you and send love
out to those that aren't as fortunate
whenever you feel like you can't afford
something this is my favorite just go
virtual shopping start coming from a
place of financial freedom and clicking
and putting in your cart all of those
things you want to buy online pick
anything you want the sky is your limit
you don't actually have to purchase
anything but by virtually shopping and
feeling that financial freedom and
adding those things to your cart you're
sending a clear message to your
subconscious mind that you can have that
and then it'll be on its way
feel powerful that you have this
superpower knowledge that you are
consciously creating your reality use
this power to shape your reality and
banish the negative beliefs you have
around money our society will constantly
condition you that you need more of this
or better things and that you have to
work really really hard to achieve
things in life but not for you
you now have the knowledge that by
shifting your mindset and taking
inspired action money will flow to you
without all the bullsh
so congratulations on taking your first
step towards financial freedom remember
that you are powerful you are worthy and
you are abundant and rule number six the
last home before some very special bonus
clips is focus on the fact with leo gura
law of attraction this is a really deep
topic but we're just going to skim the
surface but it'll still be very useful
for you just in the next 15 minutes
you're going to get a lot so law of
attraction what is it basically
it's a fancy term for the following
thing law of attraction the way that i
define it very simply is that instead of
focusing on the things that you do not
want to happen in your life
you shift your focus and you think about
the things that you do want to have
happen in your life
so what's an example of this
well let's come up with an example
let's say that you're starting a
business and you're starting a new
business and it's the first time you've
started a business so it's something new
that you're going into and now when
you're starting it off you naturally
have some fears you naturally wonder
whether you're going to be able to to
launch this business you naturally
wonder whether you're going to be able
to pay the bills maybe you wonder about
whether you should hire some employees
or not you have some reservations about
that you don't know if you can pay them
and you just wonder if the whole thing
is even a good idea and maybe you're
gonna you're gonna risk losing a lot
maybe you're gonna lose and you're gonna
invest some money you're gonna lose that
and you've got all these reservations
and so as you're building this business
and you're going about your day to day
actually implementing it creating it
what's going to happen is your mind is
going to shift and it's going to focus
on all these
problems it's going to focus on the fact
that well this business simply could
fail and so you're going to be thinking
about how do i make this business not
fail why don't i go and get another
client maybe that'll help me not fail
maybe i should go do
do this thing over here that will help
me not fail and you're always thinking
about how your business could
potentially fail and you're trying to
preempt or take some sort of action
against that and basically what you're
doing is you're planning against
catastrophe that's what you're doing
that situation
that is what 99 of us do in our lives
maybe not in such a dramatic clear-cut
way as with starting a business because
not everyone starts a business and
even the people that do don't do it that
often so that's a very poignant example
but in small ways this is happening
throughout your life right you're
focusing for example on the things that
you don't like your boyfriend or
girlfriend doing in a relationship maybe
you don't like something very small you
don't like the fact that they
uh that they pick their teeth at the
dinner table or you don't like the fact
that they put their their feet up on the
on the dinner table or just something
very small like that and you're always
focusing on that and you're saying you
know why does he keep doing that why
does he keep picking his teeth at the
dinner table why does he keep putting
his feet up and you're thinking about
that and you're focusing on
again the thing that you do not like in
your life so this is happening
everywhere in your life and most people
are going through life and they're
focusing on the things that they don't
like i don't like the traffic jams that
i'm going into when i'm driving down to
work
i don't like how much money i'm getting
paid at work i don't like the
relationship that i'm in or some aspect
of it i don't like some aspect of my
health
i don't like the fact that i might have
a bad hip i don't like the fact
that i have a toothache that's bothering
me i don't like the fact that i'm
overstressed with appointments and i've
got too much on my schedule right now i
don't like the fact that i can't take a
vacation for another
seven months when i need one right now
so all these issues right and more
you've got all this coming up
but the problem is and this is what law
of attraction states is that the things
that you focus on
the things that you put your attention
to are the things that you end up
attracting more of into your life
and so this is this is a deep this is
actually much deeper than it seems on
the surface
because
what's literally happening is that you
are focusing
on these problems
and that you are creating an emotional
vibration within you your thoughts are
then soaked in the negativity of the
situation on the challenge on the
difficulty on the fear on the problem
and then you
take on that vibration
and basically it rubs off on you and
then when you're in that kind of state
of mind well
it tends to attract
those things to you and it creates a
self-fulfilling prophecy effect and this
is not some new age concept
this is not some woo idea that
literally your thought is somehow
pulling something negative towards you
although that is literally the effect
but it's not through some weird
metaphysics that is happening not
through magic this is happening because
your thoughts
generate the action that you take in
your life and so you are not going to go
out there and take resourceful action
you might not take any action at all
when your thoughts are soaked in all
this negativity and are focusing on all
the problems because what that's doing
is making you anxious it's it's making
you insecure
it's making you fearful and when you act
from that position your actions are
feeble
they are many times self-fulfilling and
catastrophic a lot of times you'll worry
about something so much that you
actually take the action that will lead
to that thing becoming true
it's a very very freaky phenomenon in
nature and a very freaky phenomenon of
human psychology this is that this is
actually the case
so what's the what's the solution well
the solution is to adopt what the law of
attraction wants you to do and the law
of attraction states that since you are
attracting these negative things with
negative thoughts you can attract
positive things with positive thoughts
and so instead of worrying about
your money situation what you do is you
think about the awesome money situation
that you're going to create for yourself
or instead of worrying about the problem
little problem area in your relationship
you focus on the larger relationship and
you focus on how great that is or if you
want to eliminate that problem then what
you focus on is not eliminating the
problem you focus on creating something
right it's about focusing shifting your
focus on the creation so what do you
want to create your relationship how
about that why aren't you asking
yourself that question
really what this is is a is a positive
side of worry
worry is about thinking and projecting
to the future all the bad stuff that
might happen
and it's about putting what if scenarios
into your mind well what if i get fired
what if i get abandoned
what if i fail at this business what if
i get
i make a speech and i embarrass myself
make a fool of myself what if i walk
into uh into the party with my fly down
and people are are staring at me you
know what if these are like worst case
scenarios
well here's one for you what if instead
of worrying about things in the negative
you started worrying about things in the
positive
how would that look well what if i go
and
in my job i actually get a promotion
next year
what if i start making more money
because i'm providing more value
what if i start doing better at school
because i'm actually studying
what if
i work on my relationship and my
relationship becomes really amazing
better than most relationships out there
and i really flip it around
what if
i go in to this this party and instead
of having my fly down i walk in there
and i'm the coolest guy there
and everyone wants to be my friend
and i make a bunch of cool friends and
connections
right
it's the positive side of worry it's
about projecting positive images now
this is very unnatural for us to do and
this is why 99
of us are not obeying the law of
attraction because we're always worrying
about stuff this is unnatural for the
human brain and what you've got to do is
you got to recondition yourself and
rewire yourself by making uh by taking
your conscious awareness and putting it
on these problem areas in your life and
saying okay i've worried about this
stuff long enough it's about time that
maybe i should try this law of
attraction deal and see if it's gonna
really pan out the way people say it is
and when you do try it and you have to
try it
with with faith and confidence and
consistency what you're gonna find is
that it really works
and the reason that it works again is
not through some metaphysical
mumbo-jumbo simply because
you become confident you have faith in
your actions you're not insecure anymore
you're excited about what you're doing
because you have these positive visions
of what you want to create and basically
what you're doing is you start to impose
your reality on the world rather than
the world's reality
mesmerizing you and when that happens
you start to feel really good and you're
able to go out there and you're actually
able to
work on your goals you're able to take
action on your goals you're not
procrastinating anymore and so through
that whole process your thoughts shape
your actions and then your actions
attract
attract whatever it is that you want in
your life
and that's basically law of attraction
think about the things that you want not
the things that you don't want now as
simple as that sounds
you're not going to do it it's just it's
really hard to recondition yourself you
have to be very persistent with it but
if you do if you undertake this
initiative and you say you know what i
think there's something to this law of
attraction and i think i'm
it's about time that i try something new
because i'm frustrated with the lack of
results that i've been getting
and you really buy into it and you
really give it a good go give it a good
go for a month or two where you're just
constantly focusing on the things that
you want to create in your life and
you're not focusing at all on things
that you're worrying about or that you
typically would worry about you're going
to find that you're going to feel very
good you're going to start to develop a
good mood you're going to start to be
more cheerful and happy and you're going
to get this sense of confidence you get
the sense that yeah i own my life i'm in
control of my life i can actually direct
my life because i'm creating some
positive vision and then i'm going out
there and taking action towards it and
that action seems somehow smoother it
seems somehow uh
more effortless than it was before
and you're feeling good about yourself
and you just start to notice that it's
almost like magic things start to click
and you start to see that this is why
some books or some authors or just
popular culture will say that law of
attraction is is this metaphysical thing
where it's like you're literally your
thoughts are attracting things into your
life that's almost what it's like
because if you take the action component
out of it and that's actually what it
becomes is that if the quality of your
thoughts are improved then the quality
of the things that you have in your life
will also improve but what some people
do is they'll discount the intermediary
there which is action
because your actions are created by your
thoughts right your actions don't just
happen spontaneously and there's two
sides to it there's
i mean two aspects there's the conscious
thoughts that you have and the
subconscious thoughts and really what
law of attraction is really really
powerful at is
working on your subconscious because
once your subconscious starts to
resonate with that feeling of confidence
that pride that you have that sense that
everything's okay in the world that
calmness that happiness that you have
that joy when you start creating from
that
your subconscious doesn't resist anymore
you don't have those fears holding you
back you're out there you're taking
bolder action and you're you're
fulfilling it you're not quitting you're
not struggling as much it's not as much
as a grind it's more pleasant and when
that's happening
how could you not attract the things
that you want this works for everything
this will work for wealth this will work
for relationships this will work for
businesses this will work for your
health literally anything that you want
in your life you can attract by simply
focusing on the fact that you want it
rather than the fact that you don't have
it
the law of attraction definitely works
most people just get it wrong most
people only focus on the thinking part
and not the most important part which is
the action right law of attraction it's
the last five letters that matter a c t
i o a c t i o n six the last six letters
that matter action action action
thinking about it alone is not enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you wanna
manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it
and believing in it is already a big
step ahead of where most people are most
people live in a negative zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're gonna focus on your new goal your
new habit the new thing that you want
into your life amazing you believe that
it's possible amazing you're putting up
a vision board with it on your wall
amazing you're researching and watching
videos like this every day amazing
that's great that's the first starting
point but nothing happens until you take
action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but
you're still just gonna be this super
smart super ambitious person sitting at
home not achieving your goals you have
to do something i look at my youtube
channel as an example uh my main channel
i want to get to 10 million subscribers
that's my next goal right we hit one we
hit two i gotta hit 10.
uh at the rate that we're growing it's
not fast enough like it's gonna take me
way too many years to make it happen so
i need to apply more pressure against it
so
part of what i look at every day now in
my morning routine is i want to hit my
goal i want to get 10 million
subscribers on my youtube channel right
i want to be
you know one of the first
uh thought leaders experts business
person to have 10 million subscribers on
a youtube channel it's my next goal
great writing that down every day
doesn't make sure that it's going to
happen what am i doing
right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am i actually doing well i'll tell
you what i'm doing now
one of the biggest things i'm working on
now big new initiative for my team is
i've got 6 000 public videos on my main
channel and
i told my team this week i want to go
back and update all of the thumbnails in
all of the titles across all my videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6000
videos imagine doing split tests on all
of those videos
i asked for 10 a day and so two key
people on my team are working together
to come up with what the title is going
to be and then the other ones doing the
graphic design to create the thumbnails
maybe it works the first time but maybe
it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6000 videos 10
videos a day
you know in a year if we did it for 10
videos every day we're just over half of
those videos assuming that they all work
out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome i might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 slit tests a day 40 split tests a
day 100 split deaths a day i don't know
but it's happening through action right
so it starts with the idea if you have
the idea but you're not taking action
you won't get results if you just have
the action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're going in circles
without any clear direction most people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners and so watching
this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching dan lok's content alone is not
enough it's the essential first piece of
the ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible that your dreams are within
reach is super important i do it every
day it's why i create all these channels
i think you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up
but then yourself to go take the second
step
it's why after every video i have a
question of the day or i have a
three-point landing question because i
want you to take action you need to
teach yourself that after every video
you watch up to every podcast you listen
to after every book that you read
but that's not enough you have to do
something about it i'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less
if you're taking action on the ideas
that come to you because most people are
just professional
consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your life so you go watch
netflix all day when you get home for
five hours and then go to sleep right
you're a professional consumer but
you're consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action so you're not
allowed anymore you're new standards
you're raising your standards for
yourself you're not allowed anymore to
watch a video to read a book to listen
to a podcast to consume anything without
taking some kind of immediate action
towards it immediate action immediate
action it may not be the big thing
if you want to hit a million subscribers
on your youtube channel great what's the
immediate action film a video today make
an improvement to your thumbnail today
reach out for an interview for someone
today right immediate action teach
yourself that as soon as you get an idea
you do something about it because that's
the only thing that you're missing the
only thing that you're missing is
momentum if you're watching this channel
you believe in your talent you know
you're capable of more you've got big
goals big ambitions big dreams for
yourself the only thing you're missing
is momentum so to activate the law of
attraction pay attention to the last six
letters action and start doing something
about it if the person's doing the
vision board and they're saying when i
get my new car i get my new house i get
my new relationship
then i'm going to feel so great now that
well then they're back to the program
waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so
the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state for
them to feel like it's already happened
now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful
you feel a love for life you feel a joy
for existence
you feel a passion
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened it's the moment that we start
feeling those self-limiting emotions
that we feel separation and then we
start looking for it again well then if
you're waiting you're not creating
you're you're in separation again so
then yeah so then whatever it takes for
you to move into a state of being and
what is a state of being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you come come back
to your senses with a clean slate and
you say i don't feel anything you say
well let me start thinking about all the
problems in my life well all those
problems are connected to different
people or different objects of things at
different times and places the moment
you remember your problems a memory is a
record of the past you're thinking in
the past every one of those problems has
an emotion associated with them so all
of a sudden you start feeling unhappy
you start feeling bitter you start
feeling frustrated so now your body's in
the past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel from
the vision they're creating the more
altered they feel inside of them the
more they're going to pay attention to
the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated in by the universe
into wealth you will be initiated into
health you'll be initiated into freedom
those people
all those people that have healed
themselves of all those different health
conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great that
they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've they've left that program behind
a long time ago they actually don't care
how you think of them they they actually
are so happy with themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
when you think a deliberate thought
of what you want
um then law of attraction will employ
the universe and all people
circumstances and events
to
move you to what you've asked for and to
move what you've asked for to you
and so
if if if you think about that
there is just action
would be really really hard for you to
reach all of the people circumstances
and events manipulate all of them
to receive what you want and if you
really reflect well on your life and
things that have happened in your life
you'll kind of see that
actually that happened for me
all i did was move to here or all i did
was move to there and
i received what i wanted
thought creates all of the appearances
in the world and thought creates
everything in your life
so it's pretty darn powerful right
and what you think about is what you get
what you focus on is what will manifest
in your life and everyone is manifesting
their day every single day we're doing
it um we are not aware of course
necessarily of thoughts but
thoughts come we energize them and then
they will manifest unless we
cancel that thought out
um
with another thought with a thought that
contradicts it but i remember lester
levinson would say every single thought
manifests
and i just thought that was incredible i
had known the secret for years and years
and years and lester levinson was a real
master
um and he said every single thought
manifests and i was just wow
that's how powerful they are
so
so thoughts are your superpower
to be do and have what you want to
experience and have and do in your life
and and so if you ask
um an athlete or if you talk to a coach
a really brilliant coach right of a
sports team then you will find that
visualization and these principles that
i'm talking about are a big part of
their training
they have to be they have to see
themselves winning the game they have to
see themselves winning the match there
is a really incredible tennis player
that's a very big fan
a champion tennis player that's a really
big fan of the secret who uses the
sacred this is what he does he sees that
he has won the match before he walks out
onto that court and and it's the same
for
um
for teams it's the same for athletes in
the olympic games running a race and
seeing that they've won yes they run the
race but
what has them win the race
is that
they saw themselves winning before they
even got on the starting block
and they saw it and believed it and felt
it and so they just everything lined up
for them in the perfect way they drew
the perfect lane everybody else was was
moved in exactly the right position and
they got a really great start and they
won the race
and so
thought is just so so powerful so
athletes but also do you know the
astronauts in the apollo um
program did visualization
before they went to the moon and
they visualized
landing back not
[Music]
so if available took a person who had
zero resistance
and you locked them in a room
you know if you took a person that had
zero resistance that person thought
about what they wanted zero resistance
lock them in a room what they wanted
will come to them
the universe will move people
circumstances and events and bring that
right to them
it absolutely must because if you have
no resistance you have unleashed a law
that just cannot be stopped
and so you will manifest it will come to
you i want to explain something to you
that not many people really understand i
want to talk about the law of attraction
do you know that the law of attraction
is always working it's like the law of
gravity if i let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is the law of
gravity anything heavier than earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work
well
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now the subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was you're just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think
x-type thoughts therefore you're going
to be in an x-tight vibration
and that will produce
x-type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in
and that dictates how you act but it
also dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract
is the music that is tuned in to the
vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration
you can change your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you've got
to change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that y-type done the paradigm will
kick it out you know why it's so
uncomfortable
that's stepping out of the box that's
doing things different and we don't like
to do things different because it causes
a lot of discomfort
but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in their results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen
in 1961 a man gave me this book and he
said do exactly what i tell you he was
giving me y type ideas it caused an
enormous amount of discomfort but i did
exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from 4 000 to 175 000 in
a year and then i took it over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you
watch this over and over and over again
there's a number of lessons in here many
people come to me and say i want to be a
millionaire i i and there's a great song
about i'm going to be a millionaire and
they read things like the secret which
says if you want to be a millionaire
just just wish it and it will happen
and that's not quite enough i've worked
with many many many millionaires and i
became on myself quite a long time ago
now never having possibly thought that
could ever happen when i was at school i
was going to be a nanny that's how much
i thought i could earn in my lifetime
that's what i thought i was meant to be
but then i worked with so many
multi-millionaires and billionaires and
i really understand
how to attract money how to attract
wealth i'm going to take you through
today
why you haven't yet become a millionaire
there's several things that will stop
you here's the number one
you don't believe you are worth it you
may want money you may long for money
but if you have an inner belief that
says i'm not worth it not only wouldn't
you attract that money if you did you
would get rid of all of it so if you
wish to become a millionaire you must
decide you're worth it the more
reasons you can decide you're worth it
the more you'll have that motivation
that fire that drive to go out
and make a lot of money the second thing
that will make you become and stay a
millionaire
is working out how much good you will do
with the millions that you make you see
bill gates what an amazing guy he says
that in 20 years
malaria won't exist because he is using
his money
to wipe out malaria that's an
extraordinary thing and he deserves all
the wealth he has for that reason alone
if you can think of something that you
could do or
the people you would help an impact by
becoming a millionaire the more reasons
you can come up with the more people you
can help the more reasons you will have
to become and stay a millionaire and
here's the third thing and this is so
important many people think well i'm
just going to float around and manifest
millions i'm just going to sit at home
on my sofa and manifest millions if you
want a job you go out and look for a job
if you want a new home you go out and
visit new homes you want a partner you
better go out and put yourself in front
of people
and if you want to make and keep
millions
you need to decide what are you going to
do
to make those millions what gift or
talent do you have that you can monetize
you may say i don't have anything but
that's not true if you really take a
while you can find a gift a unique skill
set you have that you could monetize you
see some of the smartest people in the
world they don't invent a part they take
an existing product like james dice and
he took a hair dryer
he took a fan heater he took a vacuum
cleaner he took a hand dryer and he made
them better
and many many people take an existing
product to make it better and become a
millionaire that way
it's not about shall i invent something
i don't have an inventive mind i'm not
creative
it's about an idea you may come up with
a new product you may take someone
else's product for instance shapewear
wasn't new when spanx came on the market
and became a multi
multi-million dollar company they didn't
invent a new product well they sort of
did they took an existing product they
made it so much better
and you can do that too
but the biggest blocks i see with
budding millionaires are these things
one is
i'm going to be a millionaire i'm going
to be a millionaire and they just try
and imagine in the future and the thing
about the mind is the human mind doesn't
future pace very well
one of the reasons depressed people
can't snap out of it is because they
can't future pace and by the way if this
is making sense to you please like
please share please subscribe to my
channel and show to other people who
also want to make money why wouldn't you
want to make money you can do great
things for others when you make money
but they don't know how
they've been deluded by these
manifestation rooms sit at home and chan
on shanti
and money will fall from the heavens we
all know
that's not true
so if you want money you must be able to
visualize but it must be now you must be
able to think of
how you're going to what could you
possibly do to make money
remember that woman who changed the face
of a floor mop they made a movie about
her and she became a millionaire and she
was a housewife but one day she was
mopping her floor you know this is not
really a good mop and she recreated and
reinvented a floor mop and
has made millions that way
but here's another big block you have to
work hard many people think well i just
manifest i just sit at home
the best plan in the world will not work
if you don't work
so people get this really weird belief
that people who make millions don't work
they just manifest it falls from the
heavens they float around doing a little
stuff here and there and that's not true
i work with millionaires and
billionaires and they do work hard they
work long and they work hard on their
way to success they work a lot when they
get success
of course they can take time out but you
see when you do what you love and love
what you do it never really feels like
work i love what i do
i do what i love often say i feel like
i've never worked a day in my life
because i love what i do but really
i have worked out when i've written
books i've been writing for 12 hours a
day
meeting deadlines i travel all over the
world through time zones giving talks
and sometimes that's tiring i plan out
my schools and i'm there teaching
but i love it so much it doesn't feel
like work but if you believe you can be
a millionaire
and not have to change anything or do
anything or work hard you will probably
never be a millionaire
you have to work hard you have to apply
yourself the best plan will not work if
you don't you have to have phenomenal
extraordinary
self-belief
and finally you have to put yourself
around other people who've made money
ask them what did you do what happened
to you you see i met wayne dyer many
years ago and he said somebody always
remembered do not die with your music
still inside and i thought wow
i'm one of the best therapists in the
world and i can't die with my therapy i
mean i need to create a course make a
school teacher to other people i was so
glad i listened to him
and i've listened to many people who say
the same thing i didn't go to university
i didn't have a child background i
wasn't born into money but i had a dream
a vision and i
married that vision to very hard work i
kept going
please don't think successfully will
never get rejected they do
but they bounce back they come back they
have unshakable
unwavering confidence they have drive
and determination
so take a few minutes and just get out
of the notebook or on your phone write
out all the reasons why you would like
to be a millionaire
all the good things you could do if you
were a millionaire the people you could
help
and then decide
what industry you could go into you're
going to invent something create
something and some of the smartest
people create things entirely by mistake
look at what other millionaires have
done read some books written by
millionaires there are many
read richard branson reid felix dennis
look at some stories of millionaires and
decide if they can do it i can do it
this is a template
and i'm going to follow that template
and if you have the belief the vision
the work ethic the drive
and the confidence you will become a
millionaire
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to manifest abundance with gabby
bernstein check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there there are six common blocks to
abundance and we all experience them in
different ways
the first block is a lack mentality and
when we have a belief system around lack
we create more lack in our life